that doesn't look very scary there is no
way in hell this kid could see the TV
screen from this angle and from behind
all these people denim shirt and denim
pants together even if it's
period-accurate it's still a sin forget
how dinosaurs are made I want to know
how John Hammond gets from the
helicopter to the trailer without one
person seeing him I own an ion at least
it from the gun so do you own it or do
you lease it space aliens stole my fate
exactly the kind of article I would
expect archaeologists and paleo
botanists to hang on the fridge despite
how careful andrea is holding his bag
full of embryo money someone steals it
without him noticing calculator watch
during flight we see Hamid is seated
next to the window and then the
helicopter is obviously moving in this
direction meaning Hamid is on the
aircraft's left side but then when it
lands Hammond is now sitting all the way
over by the other window on the right
side these jeeps are just now backing up
but in the overhead shot while the
helicopter was landing they were already
in place so wait the real John Hammond
is planning to stand here once the park
opens all day every day doing his live
action lines opposite the movie version
of him for every single tour group oh
he's going to tell you but he won't
offer any explanation for how they got
the DNA to recreate the extinct plants
like the one you saw in the Jeep the
robot arms holding the hatching egg in
place completely disappear from one shot
to the next John the kind of control
you're attempting is it's not possible
calm down Malcolm I'm sure nothing could
possibly go wrong
red Raptors they told you they had a
t-rex here a Raptors really that big a
surprise you stood on the shoulders of
geniuses to accomplish something it's
almost like he's talking about
cinemasins
no one touches their lunch and they all
leave for the tour without eating a
thing
Jurassic Park Tour blows its water Lee
by putting the t-rex paddock on the
second stop of the tour any
self-respecting theme park would know to
put the t-rex last everybody stay here
Ellie just lets this little kid run into
what she thinks is a possibly dangerous
situation okay so the trike didn't eat
the lilacs and Ellie couldn't find any
lacks in the trek but does the movie
still saying they ate the lilacs does
anybody care about the fate of the
strike in this movie no okay
man this company in djenne is really
awful they don't even spell
Tyrannosaurus or Stegosaurus right XS
Lane program great he's not typing the
commands he's speaking how do I do the
tour jeeps return to the visitors center
on the same pink track the setup of
using the same track to return means
you'd have all your tour cars going in
opposite directions at the same time on
the same track
well engine got one
people can use the glass as a field in
case of a t-rex attack earlier we saw
the t-rex standing next to this fence
and then suddenly there's a huge clip
that is way the deeper than a t-rex is
tall awesome shot but shouldn't the
t-rex be closer to the Jeep that even
Steven Spielberg cannot resist the lure
of poop and snot ganz heli jumps over
the same log twice
dr. grant how do you expect to catch
Timmy if he jumps when you're standing
so far away
also the fence turns sharply to the
right in this shot but then turns to the
left in the next shot and that's
assuming you even needed to climb the
fence in the first place considering
that it appears to end just one section
away from where you chose to climb with
this fence even shock him since he's not
grounded at all this game warden waits
into the last possible moment to make
his weapon fully ready to fire this
Raptor is looking directly where the
kids are and somehow doesn't see them oh
you can move you're on the wrong end of
the door be helping much anyway let
reboots the system using some kind of
flight simulator
that is one big pile of shit